Ethan tries to convince himself that he isn't totally obsessed
with an Isa and that he doesn't want to leave his wife and that
that wouldn't be something he'd jump at at the first opportunity.
Okay, Ethan is going to try to convince himself. It's possible
that Ela's picked up on it and Ela is like actually giving him
over it. So, he's like, "Look, I'll roast her. Okay, I'll roast
her for you, Ela. Okay, Ela, get off my back. Ela, get off my
back. Okay, I will roast her on the podcast. I'll prove to you
that I am not obsessed with this woman." Okay, that's where I'm
That's where I see that's how you build a narrative. That's what
I think is going to happen here. And now I'm going to I'm going
to find every little every little thing. I'm going to be like
Drew Pavlo, okay? I'm going to just build around this
versus Idubbbz Ana. I saw Ethan totally totally totally obsessed
with Idubbbz and Ana again today. Apparently Idubbbz and Ana
went live. They did their their review Critical Drinker first.
Well, hold on. But I I don't know if I want to watch the Critical
Drinker review. Maybe I will. Is it? You know what? We'll watch
it. It's 10 minutes. It's 10 minutes. There's more. There's more
of a Drew. I can't listen to Drew anymore. He's He's looping
on the same critiques over and over again. Okay. Watch the whole
movie first. Yeah, we'll watch we'll watch Shrinker after. We're
going to move on from Superman. Okay. We're going to move on
from Superman. We're going to do Ethan Klein being absolutely
obsessed with Idubbbz and Ana. Okay. So, the the thing is, >> holy
God, >> this is the video they watch on their stream. All
right.
And here's a time stamp for the stream. We got both. We will
watch both.
>> So they're making >> So So this is Oh, wait. I
went Oh, wait. They got the whole thing timestamped now. We can
just start. We just started the time stamp. Where is it? Ana
Ida. Oh, I don't even see it in the time stamps here. But talking
about Ian and Ana's podcast right here. >> We'll go to
here. They spend like a bunch of time. They spend 40 minutes
talking about this 4-minute video. And it's just Ethan laughing
at them like being poor. And I just I think it's really funny
that he's like so absolutely
obsessed with it. Like crazy obsessed with it. Some of the comments
I heard like one com I just I was checking around for content
today. I heard one comment I'm just like no way. There's no way.
So I want to watch it first. I want to see cuz I want to see
it from my perspective and see like what's bad about it. Okay.
I just want to see. We'll check it out.
>> So this is uh Ethan, sorry Ian Idubbbz and Ana have
their podcast. They're doing an episode without furniture. I
think they're talking about their move and stuff and how they
don't have money. I think that's what's going to be funny >> Body
hair, >> okay, and facial hair. His name is
>> Okay. And he said that America deserves 911. And all
of those three things equal some people might not find this funny,
but somebody posted, you know, timbits or like donut holes on
Twitter and was like, "What do you guys call these?"
>> And Preszo named said what he called them, which I'm
not going to repeat. >> It had 911 in it and the fler and
some
>> they look pretty good. Is this present day? This is
present day. Yeah, it's just a recent recent episode. >> Was
like the kitchen sink. >> Um, okay. So, here's the [__]
deal. >> We're poor.
>> Sorry. Sorry. >> News flash. We're poor.
That's why we're in the basement for a third or fourth week in
a row. I thought we'd be able to get out of here by now. People
in Canada, let me know. News flash, we're
>> my Canadian viewers are
>> Oh, struggling.
>> Okay, so
>> No, the reason it's doing that is because this cable
>> is very finicky. Very sensitive.
>> Dude, they've got all kinds of like production issues.
>> it just takes one of the dumb dogs.
>> Dumb dogs. The Arser's coming back though in style.
He's making a little bit of a resurgence. So is the Esler, I've
noticed. I mean, I think uh you know, a lot of these uh I think
people are just kind of realizing that comedy >> is about
shocking people at the end of the day. >> But social transgression,
welltimed social transgression. Yes. >> And it had to go
away for it to come back and be funny again. >> So I think
that, you know, it'll come back and then it'll stop being funny
cuz everyone's doing it and then it'll go away and it'll come
back. It just, you >> the only for comedy again. The only
funny joke I've seen uh pertaining to that lately has been presos
um somebody on Twitter you I'll send you it because it's a I
I don't know some people might not find this funny but somebody
posted you know timbits or like donnut holes on Twitter and was
like what do you guys call these >> wait why is this looping
back
>> and preso named said what he called >> I'm just
looking for like what Ethan could be offended by here but I don't
know if he's actually offended I think he just wants to go in
on these This is not entertaining. It's not good, but I'm like
looking at what you could be so upset about that you'd have to
do 45 minutes about it on your podcast, which I'm not going to
repeat. >> It had 911 in it and the furler and some >> right?
Okay. >> He like was like the kitchen sink. Yeah. Yeah.
And then he posted a follow-up where he was like, "Enjoy. I love
my blah blah blah." And he had it in his mouth and I was like,
"That's pretty [__] funny." >> So like that,
you know.
>> it can be funny. You just have to walk the line. You
have to walk the line and you know you got to be willing to admit
that it might not be funny to every >> So give me two seconds
here. I'll be right back. I'm listening everyone.
>> You got to use it occasionally. Here's the thing is
that like I brought this up to my friend. >> Yeah. I'm
more allowed to use cracker than Han is though. >> You
are. No, you are. All right. >> And I also think >> and
that needs to be recognized. >> You can use cracker. You
can >> He's too hairy to use cracker. Yeah. >> He
is Okay. There's There's three reasons why Hassan can't use the
word >> Brings up PowerPoint.
>> He's He has too much body hair. >> Okay. and facial
hair. His name is
>> Okay. And he said that American desires
>> and all of those three things equals you can't say cracker.
>> I apparently I can't say cracker according to my hockey
team because when I was a child to you >> the one gift
the internet has given me is that there is literally nothing
you can say to me at this point that will make me feel bad. >> Right.
You've been hardened. Your skin has been toughened. >> I
will. >> Holy cap.
Holy cap. I don't know why she'd say that. I'm very >> as
her husband, I know all the secret >> Yeah, you know how
to press a button because basically
>> it's it's all the things, but it now means something
because I'm her husband. I can say all the things if Listen,
if my husband calls me an ugly [__] with it anymore.
Uh but yeah, no, you could say literally probably anything to
me. Well, not literally anything. Um I do have to say I think
he has to become more mean to me on online. You have to be more
mean. Yeah, I'll work on that >> cuz like in private he's
so mean to me. >> Just I mean it's more like when I'm low
energy, you know what I mean? And I've had enough of her >> pulling
his leg like that. >> I'm just getting the little crusties
out of his >> At least this movie had a plot and it had
characters and things were happening. Uh so >> I guess
they're going to comment on super. Dude, I I just wanted to watch
that. It's like a awful I dude it's like not What is strange
about this is they say some of the in most insane some of the
insane strangest stuff I've ever heard is what the description
says. What was like insane there? Well, that just looked like
two people like kind of rambling
like meandering around the comingings and goings of their lives
with no purpose and no nothing. What what was upsetting there
that they do 45 minutes on? >> Yeah. Well, I agree. That's
why you have to be skeptical of these. >> I don't like
Chad TBT. Anyway, let's watch this one more. >> A snarker
>> for real.
>> Anyway, here is um >> we'll watch cuz I I just
like how obsessed Ethan is.
>> From their um I believe this is their Patreon podcast.
Is that right? Is this Can you find where this is? I believe
they have about 300 people watching this. Maybe less, frankly.
And um >> you just saying that to be mean or >> No,
no, I'm being genuine. If you check their Patreon, it shows how
many >> I see. How many subscribers they have? >> It's
It's very low. Um we can check, >> we'll see. Idubbbz Patreon
>> maximum damage. >> Listen, I don't know enough
about Idubbbz and Ana either. I get how obsession can make it
funny. Maybe this will be funny. >> Maximum damage. >> Ethan
admitting to leaking members only content. Well, it would be
very interesting if you thought that was super bad to do, wouldn't
it? >> But I can't speak for the internet. The internet
might have blame. >> He has one here just himself. He's
getting $150 per month.
>> It has It has 622 members. >> Oh, you're looking
at the wrong one. >> But that's But who's this? >> I
don't know. >> 223 members. >> Paying 150 a month.
>> it's free to
maximum >> maximum damage. >> Let's see here. >> So,
622. >> So, they're making $700 a month. >> that's
very interesting that his payw wall content is going up like
or items paid up uh payw wall content is going up. Ethan's suing
intentionally. Tenstone has an interesting point here. I think
Ethan is going to start towing the line on copyright infringement,
especially on his enemies cuz he really wants one of them to
sue him or at least threaten it. His lawsuits are coming under
fire, so he needs to bait them into the same behavior. That's
interesting. Oh god. >> Which is why they're doing it from
Ina's mom's basement where they're currently >> Well, they
have a studio that they normally do this in, right? >> Well,
I think that was at their house, which they sold are selling.
>> Oh, okay. Got it.
>> Yeah. No, I I've seen it. It's definitely on the for
sale. >> I thought the Skulls thing was kind of uh humorous.
>> Nope. It's not funny. But I'll tell you what, your your
despicable state of being is hilarious to me. >> Ethan
was dumping as per usual. >> So, I think he's just going
in on them. We'll see. K. I don't think Ethan got the dog in
him to really go hard on this, right? If Ethan wanted to, he
could start mocking everything about how poor they are, but that's
not what his audience wants, right? Do his audience really want
him to be the guy who's like, "You're poor. You're look at look
at your disgusting walls, your disgusting stained walls because
you can't afford to like actually clean your house at any regular
interval or something like that, right?" Like there there'd be
critiques or or funny ways you could make it funny. I don't think
he got the dog in them. We'll see. >> Let me show you what
dumping is. Let me reopen this.
>> So, okay. Sorry. There's 600 people watching this potentially.
I mean, what's the chance they all watched it? >> Well,
that's true. There's 600 members, >> 300, I think, is a
generous estimate. >> I mean, you know, it's a big commitment
to sit down and watch podcast. >> So, any we're going to
watch this and laugh at them.
>> Too much body hair. Okay. And facial hair. His name
is Hassan. Yeah. Okay. And he said that there's nothing. >> This
is like a preview. Whoever put this together,
but somebody not it restarts. >> No, Timbits are like,
"Don't hold this on Twitter." And was like, >> "So, again,
this is one of those points where it's like clearly Ethan's watched
this multiple times. >> What do you guys call these?" and
Preszo named said what he called them which I'm not going to
repeat. It had 911 in it and Eler. >> Okay, so here's the
backing. Um, so this is where it starts. >> Erase your
memory.
>> It didn't make any sense. It's poorly edited. I'm not
just going to say it. >> Okay, so here's the deal. >> We're
poor. >> Now, I would I first of all, I would never say
this about anyone else. I wouldn't because I >> So, first
of all, I'm going to say some really mean things here that I
would never say about anybody else, but I'm going to say some
really mean things, guys. Okay, some mean stuff's coming up.
I would never call other people poor. I'm just going to laugh
at them being poor. Are they really getting divorced or is that
just wishful thinking? I think Ethan is trying to drive the idea.
And maybe maybe this is true that like Ana married Idubbbz for
money and now Idubbbz is broke. They're broke and she doesn't
love him. Actually, she's like a moneyhungry
and she's going to leave him. I think that's the narrative he's
driving at. Okay. So, we'll we'll see. >> I wouldn't because
I just don't think it's a nice thing to point out. But she has
a hideous laugh.
>> I thought you were talking about it. It's a hideous
laugh. >> No one's arguing. >> It's forced the problem.
>> Oh my god. >> What was so fun? Did I miss something?
>> No, that's part of what's hideous. >> It's forced.
It just make >> This is awful.
This is terrible. She's got Okay, you don't like her laugh. You're
never going to like the laugh of people you hate. Okay, at a
base level, you're just not going to love it. But what what are
they saying? What's funny here? They're Well, obviously Idubbbz
is laughing at people on the internet talking about their financial
situation when they don't really know what the financial situation
is, right? They're selling their house and maybe they're like
underwater on it possibly, but I don't I don't know if we know.
I don't know if anyone knows. Idubbbz would have made a money
over his career and if he in if he invested it correctly, he
could obviously be in a I think totally financially like set
position. No, Ethan forcing the hate is cringe. Well, it can
be good. Jay Hunar arc. Okay, it can be good to force hate. It
can be good to to just like roast people, but to just say, "Oh,
your laugh sucks."
Do some analogies. Who else is it like? Make fun of her. Make
fun of how she laugh. Make fun of how it's like clearly fake.
How nothing could be funny here. Make fun of anything. But they
just look fine. They just look like they're laughing and happy.
It doesn't look like anything weird's going on. You have to create
a narrative. Okay. You have to You have to tell a story. And
he's not telling any story. He's just being lazy. He's just like,
"Her laugh sucks. Doesn't her laugh suck, guys?" And then everybody
talks for 5 minutes. What? Okay. This proves Ethan doesn't watch
Red Bar. That's what I put in my thing. It's like, is Ethan trying
to do his Red Bar imitation again? Is he going to try to emulate
red bar once again and totally fail to do it? Yeah, I think that's
what he's going for. >> It just sounds hideous and I just
think she is a hideous, not physically, but I mean like soul
her whole being, her essence as a person. I just point that out.
Okay. Okay. But most people, everyone else their smile is beautiful
and you should >> uh on that. I you can't on that. Okay.
Don't on that. Don't go. Well, no, not not physically. She's
like attractive or whatever. We do know that Ethan is has a total
obsession with Ana, right? >> Never make fun of someone's
laugh or smile because it's so intimate. >> That's those
are words you live by >> for the most part. Yeah. Except
for her. She's has a hideous laugh. >> So now my narrative
for this segment is Ethan tries to convince himself that he isn't
totally obsessed with Ana Ja and that he doesn't want to her
and leave his wife and that that wouldn't be something he'd jump
at at the first opportunity. Okay, Ethan is going to try to convince
himself. It's possible that Ela's picked up on it and Ela is
like actually giving him over it. So he's like, "Look, I'll roast
her. Okay, I'll roast her for you, Ela. Okay, Ela, get off my
back. Ela, get off my back. Okay, I will roast her on the podcast.
I'll prove to you that I am not obsessed with this woman. Okay,
that's where I'm That's where I see that's how you build a narrative.
That's what I think is going to happen here. And now I'm going
to I'm going to find every little every little thing. I'm going
to be like Drew Pablo. Okay, I'm going to just build around this
narrative. >> We're poor. That's why we're in the basement.
Damn, bro. That's >> No, this is my favorite kind of comedy
cuz it's like so edgy and so ironic where you don't know if it's
serious or not. And that's like so funny. >> This is what
us lit majors call a comedy of errors. This man has made every
mistake there is and he is destitute. He's lost it all. >> Lit
majors. Highbrow over here. >> The comedy of heirs. >> Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Fair. >> It's a comedy. It's a tragic comedy.
>> It resembles >> I believe he hates it. I'm sure
>> you know hubus. The downfall of hubris. >> The
downfall of hubris. Okay. >> You know >> the downfall
like his podcast co-hosts are actually like taking digs at him
because of how bad he has been talking >> for a third or
fourth week in a row. Excuse me. She's She's coping is what it
is. She's trying to act like she doesn't care button. She cares.
>> Go for a third or fourth. >> But let me go back.
>> Go back. There's going to be a lot of You're pausing
a lot. >> There's going to be a lot of I'm taking a lot
of joy in this. >> So, basically, are they poor? >> I
think so. >> But he's saying it in a way where it's like
I'm just joking or not. You >> just a map. They don't work.
>> They don't work. >> The creator clash disaster
aside. These two people don't work.
>> And whatever money they had saved up, I'm pretty sure
they lost a substantial somebody bankrolled that. Although she
was bragging about how jokes's on you, dude. We didn't risk anything.
Yeah. Either way, I mean, >> that's a good business partner
right >> Yeah, for sure. >> If he actually manages
to be broke right now, that's like, oh my god, you're so stupid.
Cuz he >> I if it ever if they go like buy a nice house
and just live a nice life for the rest of their lives, they look
so bad, right? Like these guys are literally the everybody on
this podcast, right? Well, Ethan and Eva, okay, are actually
publicly jerking off to the idea that that Idubbbz and Ana might
be financially destitute,
which can be funny if you don't alo also virtue signal that you're
a good person. I could throw up PPD and uh Worski right now,
Kino Casino. Okay, they could do the same thing. I would laugh
my ass off because they genuinely have no dog in that race. They
don't try to pretend they're good people. They just go hard on
people and it's funny as Right. But Ethan and Ela want to do
that under the pretense that they're still good people, that
they're still like broadly very nice and that's [__]
Okay,
>> He had no reason to end up broke. Like he you should
see the views he was getting. He was on top of the world as far
as like YouTube goes. >> Well, he was too edgy to make
money and now he's too dumb to make money. >> But he still
found a way to make money. He was doing like merch that was selling
like thousands and >> he did like one merch run when he
did the um >> the sheep. >> The sheep and he got
he got lucky cuz he was edgy. We all thought that was funny at
the time. But now edgy isn't that funny. Or just saying like
the isn't really like comedy, right? >> He should have
at least been able to pocket a few millions. Like >> nope.
They're hiding out in a basement in Canada. >> That's why
we're >> And their house is up for sale literally. Like
that's not even a joke. >> News flash. We're >> I
again I just feel like I've never seen Idubbbz flashing wealth
or opulence in any way. So I don't know how he would be poor,
right? Am I crazy? Does this guy drive around in like luxury
cars? Is he like getting, you know, $100,000 watches? How did
he end up poor if he made millions of dollars and he just lived
in LA? Like, I actually don't know. They could be poor. I just
don't know how you got poor after having such a massive YouTube
channel for so long. Maybe you put it all into Creator Clash.
I don't know how you could actually. Only poor people sell their
homes. Yeah, I don't know. >> Poor. That's why we're in
the basement for a third or fourth week in a row >> and
we're making no effort. >> The cringe didn't really hit
me until you played it uninterrupted. >> Okay, let's go
back. I'll go back again. No, keep playing it >> for a
third or fourth week in a row. I thought we'd be able to get
out of here by now. >> They've made no effort to make this
look better. In fact, this is even more sad. Just the one plugged
in mechanism with the wire showing. Guys, >> I He wasted
a bunch of money developing a game that never came out. Oh, well,
that could be a thing. I didn't know that. Interesting. Okay.
Yeah, it seems like they're intentionally doing it this way to
feed into the poor aesthetic, but they've been doing that for
a long time. They love the poor aesthetic. That's all of Ana's
tattoos. They portray themselves as white trash and they've done
so for like years as far as I know, right? Like they they love
leaning into this aesthetic all the time.
I I feel like you're you're helping them like rebrand themselves
as this. Interesting. I wonder how much
members they look like this room that we set up. >> You
know what's funny though? I just >> they're they're in
a deprivation room. >> Yeah, they're called podcast lazy.
I just remember it lazy and he said it's not what podcasting
cuz it's just emotional dumping ground like bro >> and
no creative work and nothing to be proud over something like
that right >> how the are you actually you are so stupid
and Ian we used to be friends but now look at you >> I'm
I I revel in every misfortune you guys will ever step foot in
and trust me there's a lot and there'll be more >> there'll
be more and I mean you guys are not helping your case just look
at this damn put up a green screen at least like what the is
this like for real you can be broke and still not look this sad
and >> I mean that's how all YouTubers start basically
most of them start >> let me Ana laughs like someone who
just cooked the meanest potion in a cauldron.
>> my Canadian viewers are
>> You guys hear this? Do you guys hear the laughter? She
just cooked the meanest. She's like a witch, guys. She's like
a witch, guys. Don't you think Ana is like a witch? She sounds
like she just cooked up a a potion in a cauldron, guys. She's
like a witch. You get it? She's like a >> I'm struggling.
And then their video just goes out. This is part of their
>> I thought we'd be able to get out of here by now. In
Canada, let me know. >> my Canadian viewers are >> Oh,
struggling. >> Okay, so >> No, the reason it's doing
>> is Ethan just a petty [__] these days. Well,
I believe so. Yes. I believe it's just we've gone through the
same line like eight times. I just I don't know why he wouldn't
go. Could you just tell me why wouldn't you go for quality over
quantity here? Why wouldn't you say like, "Okay, I'm gonna write
a bit or two for each of these points and I'm not going to run
through 10 times trying to like figure out new jokes on the fly.
Just like actually kill these guys." I don't think he has Tourette's.
I think he has some OCD thing where he creates these impulsive
habits because he believes it helps him say the correct things.
I have no idea. I'm not going to contemplate his OCD. I don't
>> because this cable.
>> Very sensitive. >> So the cable like >> It
just takes one of the dumb dogs. >> Ian, would you say
this is what podcasting is? I don't know what you call that.
>> You call that? Um, it's behind a pay wall, too. >> Pay?
Yeah. What the hell, dude?
>> Just to be clear, was this this wasn't live? It's live.
Maybe you would understand why that would be. Are we sure? This
is me asking. This is not me trying to live. >> And this
is what it looks like. >> I mean, do people do live on?
Is it Patreon? What is it?
>> Do people even do live? >> I think on Patreon
you can just embed like a unlisted YouTube link. Like I I don't
know if you do your own They do their own video hosting on Patreon.
>> I believe what is happening and I don't know for sure,
but this >> they do they do their own hosting on Patreon.
This is a pre-recorded video that they've posted to their >> Patreon.
Well, then that seems silly to include that. One of the uh the
benefits of joining as a member is uncut videos. So, that's these
are >> uncut. That's not the uncut part that people are
usually by uncut. Does he mean lazy? No effort, zero oversight.
>> The behind the scenes is uncut. All right. Golly, what
a bunch of losers.
>> The dumb dogs. >> Uh uncut. Is that like a criticism
of Israel? That seems un that seems anti-semitic. Okay. Oh, they
they have to release their videos uncut. What's wrong with being
cut, guys? Is it because 95% of are cut? Is that what you're
saying? That's why you release all of your videos uncut?
>> If I were like Ethan and I wanted to make terrible jokes
all the time, I'd make jokes like that. >> Darcy's coming
back though. >> Now they opine um almost jolly on how >> God
please don't I >> He can't make that joke. There's no way
for you know um >> Yeah. And that the handicap folks uh
is coming making a comeback. They're happy about it. >> They're
behind that movement. >> Wait, it gets worse. >> Whatever.
which again which is a horrible slur which needs to absolutely
stay dead as well as the rur but that slur for gay folks is really
one of the top three worst slurs there is no one ask what circles
are you in >> I mean the is definitely trumps >> I'm
sorry I thought you meant to them to that community the f word
>> oh yeah >> I think just in general it's one of
the worst up there >> no but like saying you're seeing
the rword is one thing to say you're seeing the f word come back
what circles are you in cuz I do not see that >> me neither
even like >> I don't how do you okay is definitely coming
back it has been coming back for a while circles Are you in that
you haven't seen the flor coming back? >> The edgy kids
who are saying the R word now are not dropping f bombs. >> Are
they trailblazers? Are they >> He wants to say it. But
anyway, here let's hear him out. They they they defend it somewhat.
Interestingly, >> you know, a lot of these dumb people
are just kind of realizing that comedy is about shocking people
at the end of the >> No, no, no, no. We already did that
with >> Oh, wait. >> I thought it was making people
laugh. >> No, we learned the opposite. >> I thought
we learned this. >> We learned the opposite. No,
>> noticing. I think, you know, a lot of these uh I think
>> I think this is going to be a joke on Idubbbz saying
that it can't just be
>> right. It can't just be shocking. >> People are
just kind of realizing that comedy is about shocking people day
and it had to go away for it to come back and be funny again.
So, I think that, you know, it'll it'll come back and then >> it's
not just about shocking people. It's about welltimed
and possibly unexpected social transgression. That's what comedy
is. >> People stop being funny. Everyone's doing it and
then it'll go away. And we're talking about the floral,
>> What? Producer or something? >> Okay, got them,
right? >> I think his name's also Dan. Dane. Okay, close
enough. >> They were looking for a Dan. They found a D.
Close. >> That's just always true, by the way. That's always
true. There will be a moment in time where the furler the Fler
could be the punch line to some joke. That is [__]
hilarious.
That's just obviously true. You don't know that that's obviously
true. That's unfortunate for you. More comedy for us. >> I'm
kidding. >> Yeah. I don't look how that worked out for
them. Thanks for coming again. >> The only funny joke I've
seen uh pertaining to that lately has been Preszo's um somebody
on Twitter. I'll send you it cuz it's >> joyously recounting
the memes on Twitter she enjoys. They employ the fle. >> I
think Preso is gay though. >> Oh yeah, that does. >> This
is the worst. This is the most discussion I've ever heard in
my life. Ethan is trying to become Idubbbz to beat Idubbbz. Ethan
is somehow he is so obsessed with Ana that he is willing to become
the he says Idubbbz is in order to try to her. Okay. He is actually
he is actually trying to replace Idubbbz mentally, right? He's
actually trying to do that. He is so obsessed with trying to
[__] Isa that he will become the that he says Idubbbz
is amazing. >> I just change things. >> Yeah, that's
>> I think it's used within the gay community as >> that's
not a comeback. >> That's not
what they're talking about. >> Let's not let's not muddy
the water. That's not what they're talking about. He is just
in this particular brought up. Fair. That's fair. But I don't
think >> but gay they none of this people is gay. >> Well,
and they're talking about the Esler being funny and making >> I
mean the fler was always a thing in the gay community, >> right?
I don't think >> I don't think that ever became not cool
or unfunny. Like if you're gay, you can employ that word. >> I'm
just giving a context to that one. >> but that means you're
gay. >> If you say the furler funny joke I've
>> he's Yeah, he's actually going to go ahead and say how,
oh, you can't say any of these things. They can't be funny. He's
going to do the Idubbbz the actual Idubbbz thing. Those jokes
weren't funny. There's no way they could be funny. You can't
say that and be funny. Amazing. He's actually he's he's done
it. He's replacing himself >> pertaining to that lately
has been pres um somebody on Twitter. I'll send you it cuz it's
I don't know. Some people might not find this funny, but somebody
posted, you know, kimbits or like donut holes on Twitter and
was like, "What do you guys call these?" And >> I'm starting
to actually despise Ian's laugh as well. It's quite it's quite
forced and it just feels idiotic. It's like a low IQ laugh. It's
like a lobomized laugh. >> I think you just feel that way
cuz you despise him. >> No, I think it sounds like someone
took a ice pick to this dude. This dude's dumb. I thought you
said every laugh was unique and you Oh, no. No. It doesn't apply
to them. Okay. >> On Twitter and was like, "What do you
guys call these?" And >> no, that thing I said that doesn't
I hate these people. The thing I said that doesn't apply to them,
guys. Nope. >> No, it doesn't apply to them. >> Name
said what he called them, which I'm not going to repeat. It had
911 in it and something. Okay. >> It was like
Yeah. Yeah. And then he posted a follow-up where he was like
in I love my blah blah. He had it in his mouth. I was like, "That's
pretty." >> So like that, you know, >> I have no
idea what this tweet was based off of. I don't
>> guys Ian the n word f word guy should not even be having
this combo. He should be like whoa whoa. >> Sorry people
in the people in the discord are mentally ill. Okay. I don't
know why this was made. Why would you make this? Who made this?
This is crazy.
Some crazy. >> They should but Ian the f word guy should
not even be having this combo. He should be like whoa whoa whoa.
The f word never funny guys.
>> Never funny. It's not up to me. >> Oh no. ESMbot.
ESM bot got a hold of it. ESM bbot got a hold of it and we've
got the actual meme in full force now. Okay, there it is.
>> There it is. >> Space Ghost, thank you for the
gifted sub. I appreciate it. I don't think I reset the meter
today. I did not reset the meter, so I have to do that. Thank
you very much for the gifted sub. I appreciate it. Continue on
with uh Ethan trying to be enough of a that Ana. Listen, I'm
a and I have money. Ana, you could marry me. Ana, I'll leave
my wife. >> need to decide when that word's funny. It's
not a joke for you to even laugh at. Ana, you need to check your
white privilege. Your white straight privilege at the entrance
to that basement. Okay. When you when you descend those old cranky
wooden stairs and hobble past the cobwebs, check your privilege.
He's trying He's trying to Dude, you cannot He's like trying
to work a little bit of red bar in or something and it just doesn't
do He can't do it. He can't do it. He can't be like that kind
of hateful and it just it just does not >> funny. You just
have to walk the line. >> You have to walk the line and
you know you got to be willing to admit that it might not be
funny to everyone. >> Yeah. What is he saying? >> He's
saying that that word is funny to some and it's cool. Walk the
line, baby. Now listen, maybe am I reaching a little bit? No.
>> So was his whole was his whole arc of like I learned
my uh >> is it possible that I'm like reaching because
I hate these people? No. No. I don't want to confront that thought.
Nope. Nope. I don't I'm not >> like discussing and created
like the worst fans and all the stuff that he said. Was that
all like fake? >> I don't know how it I don't know how
it jives with that. Especially with his producer being like,
"Oh, no. Being shock." People are now realizing what's the funniest
thing is being shocking. Shock is comedy. >> So weird.
>> That's true. Then I'd be laughing when >> cuz
he he went so far as to say that basically calling all of his
fans like disgusting people. >> Well, I mean, he said he
was never going to make a content cop again. Then he made one
about me. So, his brain is all I think the lobotoize theory might
hold. There's a piece of his brain somewhere in a laboratory.
>> You got to use it occasionally. Here's the thing is
that like I brought this up to my friend. >> I'm more allowed
to use cracker than Han is though. >> Give me No, we're
not doing that right now. Parallax, you can go watch the vod
from yesterday. I covered the whole thing if you want, but I
can't do that right now. No, you are thinker.
>> I mean, look, Ian, if you're going to be the altruistic
woke king, pick a lane. You going to do the racist jokes or not?
Cracker is a very non-offensive joke, but it is directed towards
people of a white of who are white, which is obviously whiteness
as a race is uh is a complicated topic and it's not really a
thing, but it you are >> I don't know any woke people who
say cracker. That's >> focusing on people's skin color.
So, I think pick a lane, you know, are you are you the guy who's
like I've ascended or you the guy who's like, "Oh, but let's
make fun of people who are white because they have white skin."
I mean, what are we doing here? You know, pick a lane. I also
think now I'm not I'm not grasp I'm not uh uh grabbing my pearls
when people say cracker. I don't think it's offensive. I don't
think I don't think most people >> Yeah. Who cares? But
I'm just saying I'm just saying morally and philosophically
>> No. Well, yes, but no. No, not morally and philosophically
inconsistent. They believe that if you have power in a society,
if you're the colonial power, the the ethnicity that enslaved
all these people, you cannot be sorry, people cannot be racist
to you. That's their ideological like consistency, right? They
are being consistent. They don't Yeah. They don't care about
saying anti-white slurs. They think if you're white, you can't
they can't People can't be racist to you. So, you're just seething
about nothing. You just don't understand how they think or what
they're operating on. Like how they how they talk amongst their
peers. You're just seething for no reason. Trying to apply a
standard to them that they've never applied to themselves. >> You
can use cracker. You can >> It's too hairy to use cracker.
Exactly. Okay. There there are three reasons why his song can't
use the word cracker. >> Brings up PowerPoint. >> What
is that laugh? What was so funny? >> He You ever read One
Flew Over the Of >> Yeah. You remember how that book ended?
and Casey, right? >> That's how that's him. >> He
used to have personality. He used to be a vibrant character.
Now he just sits at and the off now he's just sits there
>> I see. >> They lose him. If you don't know,
I see. >> Yeah, he was. >> Ethan can't talk about
anyone being consistent ever. He's the least consistent person
ever. And let's remember that this exact lane flip-flopping is
what Ethan built his career on. I just want to go back to the
SQC thing where Ethan goes, "Yeah, like Twitch streamers reacting
to stuff. That's not as clear, guys. It's only when they post
the VODs to YouTube." Like Hassan, that's a gray area. And I
couldn't possibly comment on like whether or not that's fair.
But he was friends with Hassan. >> Labbotomized as a means
to >> I thought you were saying he was a large Native American
man who was about to >> I love that guy. He great role.
That's Chief. That was you. >> No. Damn. >> I don't
know why. I thought you were friend Chief. >> He was the
one that was lobbomized. Chief was never lobottomized. >> He
was only electrified. His brain was >> You just said the
guy at the end of the movie. He's the guy at the end. >> Yeah.
It ends with him being chief >> Oh my god. You >> spoiling
the movie. >> Spoiling. It's like 100. >> It's from
the 70s, I I do feel like on the cracker thing though, like who
actually uses that? >> Have you ever been called that in
a derogatory way? >> Like if you are talking about using
it, like you're a weirdo, right? Like why would you use it? >> I
think it can be employed in an offensive way cuz I've heard it
explained that I didn't know the origin of it is you're being
called a slave a slave drug. >> It's in reference to cracker.
>> Somebody actually uses it in a way that's like actual
like malicious like
though. I don't know. >> I thought it was like a saltine.
I didn't even understand it. >> I always thought it was
in reference to saltine like a cracker. >> Like a white
cracker. >> Yeah. When I was growing up, I thought just
like white people being soft like just soft like a cracker. What?
Crackers >> I don't think anybody I only hold on Amy. What
kind of crackers you have? Correct. I think brittle. >> Yeah,
crackers are hard unless used them. They're brittle. You're right.
They're brittle. >> We're brittle.
>> We are brittle.
>> So, as I was saying, um
uses that. I don't know. >> I agree. >> But when
I learned that it means that I was like, I can actually see that
how that could be offensive if used. But, >> you know,
but anyway, who cares? But I'm just saying he's inconsistent.
>> Porter Beller, that's a joke. You're joking. Just so
you know. I know you don't know, but you're joking. I'm saying
you're joking. I totally disavow that comment. That's That's
crazy. >> Has too much body hair. Okay. And facial >> By
the way, >> don't tell me she doesn't want that. Nobody
would do that. >> Body like girl, you did not have to go
>> He's He has too much body hair. >> This is why
they brings up our point. >> He He has too much body hair.
Okay. And facial hair. His name is Hassan. Yeah. Okay. And he
said that Americans. >> Are you counting his body hairs?
>> It's definitely uncomfortable considering Ian doesn't
have body hair and facial hair. >> Right. And and by the
way, also considering the guy who she allegedly
>> I mean she's saying too much, right? She's saying I
don't I don't like these
>> was trying to um who she was like mega into gorgeous
did appear to be a somewhat hairy more traditionally masculine
dude uh in the in the vein of Hassan, which might be her type.
>> And I'm what I'm what I'm sensing is that Ian's not
her
>> um physically. And I mean >> this could actually
be a good criticism. I actually think this could be a good critic.
Also, he smells like his breath smells like and he's his pants,
which is nobody's type. Let's be real. >> But I truly am
genuinely the happiest I've ever been there, you know. >> Yeah,
there's somebody far. >> There's always somebody. >> That's
true. I shouldn't say I shouldn't. I don't think she's into it
based on the way she described it. >> Yeah, that's fair.
>> Um, how long ago was it she said, "I'm genuinely the
happiest I've ever been." Was that just like a couple weeks ago?
>> Maybe a month. >> Maybe a month ago. >> Feels
like a year in YouTube time. >> Uh, I pulled it June 4th,
2025. >> Oh, so it's a little over a month. A little over
a month. Okay. So, I guess some I guess maybe things have changed
since then. >> Yeah. All of those three things equals you
can't say cracker. >> I apparently I can't say cracker
according to my hockey team because when I was a child, >> the
one gift the internet has given me is that there's literally
nothing you can say to me at this point that will make me feel
bad. >> Don't test me. >> Is that a challenge? >> Sounds
like it. >> Yeah, it was cap from her. That was >> you
know. Okay. Well, well, if that's true, then I should never feel
bad about anything I ever say about her. She's impervious to
uh feeling bad. I can I literally cannot harass her if you
>> So, I can keep I can keep covering an Easter every single
day. I could just cover her every single day for the rest of
this podcast history and that wouldn't be bad. Okay, I need everyone
here to agree right now that I can cover Ana every single day
for the rest of my podcast and you can't complain about it and
she can't complain about it. >> Do you believe her? >> I
don't I can't wait for the Ethan Klein when Ethan Klein goes
full Sam Hyde and does a full Ana Joa Only Fans review. Okay,
I can feel it. It's like six months away. It's coming.
>> Call her a liar. I would never. >> I feel like
you call her
once or twice. >> I wouldn't I mean in this case it seems
like she's being super genuine. So I'm just going to say for
the one time you believe her. Okay. >> Hideous laugh. I
>> I personally I don't believe her. I think it probably
does hurt her feelings just based off of the way she's reacted
>> there. There's a chance. There's a chance. But I choose
people at their >> Good way to be. >> Yeah. Thank
you, Tom.
>> Yes, man. >> My hockey team because when I was
a >> the one gift the internet has given me is that there's
literally nothing you can say to me at this point that will make
me feel bad. >> Right. Challenge accepted.
>> Hello. We'll see what we'll see what we can do. >> I
mean, I'm not saying anything right now. I'm just You're not.
>> Keep it together. >> Your skin has been tough.
>> I will say as her husband, I know all the secret ones,
you know, pressure because basically >> it's it's all the
things, but it now means something because I'm her husband. I
can say all the things. >> I feel like the hideous laugh
thing will will upset her because it's very personal and I don't
think she's heard that a lot. And it's true. Frankly, it is true.
She should feel insecure about her laugh. She needs to change
that up. >> Okay. What about it is bad. >> Can't
control that. Control your laugh. Dude, the the crew does like
absolutely despise this guy. Hold on. I was just I was on Twitter
really quick. I >> [__] my hockey team. >> I
need to rewind for a second. >> But it now means something
because I'm her husband. >> I feel like the hideous laugh
thing will upset her because it's very personal. Never mind.
I did heard that and it's true. Frankly, it is true. She should
feel insecure about her laugh. She needs to change that up. >> That
won't bother her. >> The way you laugh is the way you laugh.
>> No, you can change your laugh. People do >> But
that's not a real laugh to be fair. Come on. That's my point.
>> That's a fake laugh. >> Can you
change a fake laugh? Can you change your laugh? I think some
people don't even know how to get >> You can definitely
change your laugh
>> I feel like the >> No, no, no. You can totally
You can totally like laugh a certain way. I don't laugh the certain
the same way I did 5 years ago at all. >> Guy changed his
life, right? He laughs like Elvis now. >> Come on. >> I
guess this this is what you're saying is that if it's not genuine,
like an ingenuine laugh can be changed. >> Yeah. Like she's
doing it for the >> I feel that people can modify their
laugh. Does anyone know what I mean? >> I think laughing
is so like instinctual. Like I I I couldn't like override that.
Like if it's a genuine laugh and something made you laugh, >> she
she needs to stop being herself if that's the case. And she needs
to start being someone else. Someone who is way better than her
in every way. >> Literally just change everything about
>> Let's get back to um what she was saying. I was curious.
>> Oh, by the way, I know I know I'm being very meanspirited,
but just a reminder that they have justified calling CPS call
said accuse me of hallucinating anti. Yeah. Okay. Just reminder
for
>> Who knew that we actually signing up? Okay. We're actually
just signing up for Ethan's roast right now. Bro, dude,
there's no way that Dan just did that. We know, Ethan. We know.
We know. You've been talking about it for 18 months now. Sorry.
With CPS 5 months now, Ethan, every day. We get it.
We
get it. Even >> what she was saying, I was curious. >> Oh,
by the way, I know I know I'm being very mean-spirited, but just
a reminder that they have justified calling CPS call said accuse
me of hallucinating anti-semitism. Yeah. Okay, just reminder
for real. Just reminder
that I'm going to mean something because I'm her husband. I can
say >> Listen, if my husband calls me an ugly [__]
with
>> Are you doing that? Are you doing that? Cuz he shouldn't
be. >> he shouldn't be calling you that an ugly >> You
think she It was a hypothetical hypothetical that she was
>> It seems like they're talking about >> Let's go
back cuz she seemed to suggest that that might have been something.
>> It's It's all >> I know the stuff that offends
her. No pressure, but
>> it's it's all the things, but it now means something
because I'm her husband. I can say all the things. Listen, if
my husband calls me an ugly, but yeah, no, you could. >> Well,
how wait, how can you even speculate?
How can you even remotely speculate on what she was going to
say there when it cuts immediately? It just cuts before you get
any more analysis >> Say literally probably anything to
me. Well, not literally anything. Um, I do have to say I think
he has to become more mean to me on online. You have to be more
mean. >> Yeah, I'll work on that. >> Cuz like in
private he's so mean to me. >> Just I mean,
>> Breadcrumbs. He pretends to be nice on to me on camera,
but when we're at home privately, he's a monster. >> Breadcrumbs.
She's getting ready to leave his ass. >> Keep him away.
I got to see if that leads into something. But that >> it's
more like when I'm low energy, you know what I mean? And I've
had enough of >> Pull his leg like that. >> I'm just
getting the little crust. At least this movie had a plot and
had characters and things. >> This bro is literally a real
life dwarf. Like look at him. He literally like
wreck this dude. I don't He might be a nice guy. I don't know.
>> Yeah. What? They're just going after the random producer.
Wasn't Wasn't Ethan is Okay. I don't care. That's funny. That's
maybe the best joke he's done this whole time, which kind of
sucks for him, right? That this guy looks like a dwarf. Cuz he
kind of does. Looks like a nerdy dwarf. But haven't you gotten
at people going after your crew and when you're they're totally
unrelated to your crusade against the
>> Listen, but it's funny. Okay. It's funny. No, no, no,
no. I don't have any moral problem with him attacking producer
cuz he actually did his best. >> I'm only making fun of
you because you're with them. Don't worry. It's not >> He
does look like Orbjorn. Yes. This guy could be ass Mythral awareness.
>> I got a problem with Wait, did you say his name was
Dane? That's literally the title. Like Dne is like the leaders
of the dwarfs. I'm not kidding. >> No. Well, Dane
Dne is the king of the dwarves, right? In at the beginning of
um The Hobbit >> in Token. >> That's the name of
their Tolken. Dane. >> Oh, yeah. Dane Ironfoot. He's
>> You guys are brushing over what was just said. I crazy.
First of all, she's telling him he needs to be more mean on air.
And then she's also saying he's mean to her off air >> when
he's had enough of her. >> What's the point she's trying
to make? Because they're married. He could say anything to her.
That's not really >> Tell me the point she's making because
she's trying >> Oh, yes. Ethan, tell me the point where
it totally leads to them getting divorced and Ana like having
to you for money. Leave me there. Leave me there. I can see it.
Oh, Thane. Okay. >> She's suggesting that. >> Does
that look like that's literally >> That does look like
him. >> Shane, bro, you greed undid your whole tribe, bro.
I mean, he's a cool character, so it's like awesome. >> They
dug too deep. What happened? >> I have no problem with
Dane's look. >> What happened when they dug too deep, >> They
released the That's what you're doing right now, sitting with
them in that room. You've dug >> The funny part about this
is how uncomfortable the crew is with making fun of the producer
cuz they can feel like, "Hey, we don't like it when people go
after us because of you." Like, they're all uncomfortable with
it. >> You're digging too deep. >> Okay, now you
they got you talking about how the feler is making a comeback.
Dig too deep, Dane. >> Dad, I have a problem. >> Dane,
dig too deep. >> Apparently, he makes good TF2 videos,
so shout out. >> Well, Yeah, let's keep it that way. Let's
not
>> Let's not Let's not tank the Team Fortress 2 videos.
>> Dude, what year is it? What are you doing making Team
Fortress 2 videos? >> Still popular as hell, which I came
out like eight. >> It's crazy. It came out in like 2007,
something like that.
>> I mean, I classic. That's what I used to >> Oh,
you played TFC, baby? >> Yeah, I loved it. >> Yo,
I played a lot of TFC back in the day. I
>> uh
Listen, that's that's better commentary than everything else
here, but I don't want to risk.
>> No, you could say it. Well, not literally anything.
Um, I do have to say I think he has to become more mean to me
on online. You have to be more mean. >> So, she's saying
I think she's trying to appear to be encouraging him to be like,
"Oh, you could be yourself and you can do more banter with me."
Like, that's the aesthetic of what she's trying to say. What
she's clearly and slightly saying is that you pretend to be nice
to me on camera. You put on a show as if you're a loving husband,
but at home you treat me horribly and and it's miserable and
I'm miserable and people have no but I I don't know how you could
one I don't even know how you could say that without more context
but I think she's saying you should be more mean like you should
be more like you are in private because it's funny right >> idea
how badly you treat me at home cuz everybody thinks you're this
nice guy but you're not >> that's all there >> no
I think what's there is like you are too nice to me online you're
probably worried about the harassment I get online you should
actually be more like you are in private cuz in private you can
make a joke that's mean and funny but on in public online you
you don't you like try to protect me >> the breadcrumbs
are being laid before us >> so it's it's again another
form of throwing under the bus. >> Oh yeah, because she's
making everybody >> private off. That's a funny point as
a funny aside that nobody can do an imitation of Ethan. It's
like immediately ableist. It's like the guy who the journalist
who criticized Trump and then Trump did the hands, right? You
can't really imitate Ethan accurately without being like disgustingly
abbleist towards him. He's got he's got plot armor is >> people
the very few that are watching. >> She's making them suspect
that like, oh, things might look okay to you, but behind the
scenes it's terrible. She's she's she's laying the groundwork
brick by brick so that she's building herself a path brick by
brick to exit this >> and me and me and me finally. I've
been obsessed with this woman. I've needed to her for a decade.
I will have what I've earned. Okay. I'm rich. They're poor. She
will come to me. >> So where whereby she's the victim and
she's the good guy intact. >> Obviously that's what people
will say. >> I mean I pro they probably did not get a prenup.
I don't know. Basically, but but but I mean, listen, I I'll actually
defend her on that. She's entitled to half. They've been working.
They work together on everything. >> No, that's not what
I'm talking about. It's just that people will say she got with
him when he was at the top and making a lot of money. >> Half
of what? Half of what? I thought they were broke. What? What
is she entitled to half of? >> And now that he's supposedly
not doing well, she's going to leave him. So, people will say
she was there for the >> I think there Yeah, I mean, I
think there's I think there's part >> That's the obvious
analysis, by the way. I don't know how that's basically evaded
Ethan this whole time, but that is the obvious analysis. She
probably got with him for money. She is a gold digger. She is
going to leave him. That is like the obvious thing you would
say if you hate these people. You're trying to like drive a wedge.
>> Part of that. And I don't know if it's necessarily specifically
money. Just so that just that like he's kind of just his career,
his persona, his respect, like everything he has is just in the
>> He's in a dim basement >> just as a part just
Yeah. I mean he's there. Exactly. He's in a dim basement >> physically
and metaphorically. >> Yeah. I mean like just I mean who
who would want to be with him? >> My god. He put that peed
in my basement. >> You know what I mean? Like like >> did
you pee down there, buddy? >> My god. >> You know,
I don't even blame her for wanting to leave him, but no, she's
absolutely entitled to half and and I mean that with all due
respect. She's been working with him at 50% since she joined
the gang. That's what that's man. >> I'll work on that.
>> That's like in private so mean to me. >> Just
I mean it's more like that, Zach. >> When I'm low energy,
you know what I mean? And I've had enough of her [__]
>> Lady like that. >> I'm just getting the little
crust. >> At least this movie had a plot. It had characters
and things were happening. Uh so for that reason, I give a one.
>> Yeah. No, that's fair. Okay. I understand you're one
>> and I raise you, but I think you two are just more spiteful,
I think, which is fair. You're just like this movie. >> Yeah,
I'm an angry. >> Oh, no. I I also kind of agree. Why am
I so handsome, right? >> I want to know what movie they
were. >> Don't you have to
zero something, but I do not. Yeah, I >> And he gave it
a one. I got to know what movie they were talking about. >> You're
going to have to go >> talk about Superman. I mean, what
else big has come out recently? >> Oh, must Oh, naked.
>> So, hold on. Who hates Naked Gun? >> Who hates
then? If they're giving Superman a one
guessing exactly Mike says that I'm I'm positioning myself against
Superman because I'm a >> Zionist, right? >> Zionist.
Well, who's the Zionist now? Is he giving Superman a one? >> Literally
Zionist. >> I don't think it's impossible. >> It
must It must have been a different
the reason why more exciting than giving Superman a zero. >> You
like that movie? >> Yeah. I mean, it wasn't like the best
movie I've ever seen, but he listen Cruz from the side of a plane
for real. He's still got it.
This is rough. This is actually really rough guy. No, for real.
>> He's incredible. Scientology aside, all the weird stuff
about
>> He is a once in a generation. >> Have you seen
where he rides the motorcycle? It's on Tik Tok where he rides
the motorcycle off the cliff on his back from the last movie,
>> dude. He's insane. >> And he's a good actor, too.
>> I think I think Drew might be talking to Pisco about
the movie today. I wish I'd seen the movie. >> Super versatile.
He has earned his position as like, you know, with Jackie Chan
and Buster Kei.
He's better though because he >> in terms of being a duel
an actor that does their own stunts like the stuff that he's
put himself through. He he deserves those props. What was your
what was your uh take with that? >> I mean, no, I guess
so. I just I really like Jackie Chan. So, I love Jackie >> Jackie
Tan is the king of that. >> Jackie Tan. Exactly.
>> Jackie Tan. >> He said Jackie Tan. >> Jackie
Tan. >> Um, but Tom Crew everything crew
>> That's so crazy as a parent to do that. >> What
it's like in China is being gay >> even if you talking
about them. I'm just trying to see if they finish this video.
>> Report that for me, dude. >> Video and I've been
>> That's a laboo. >> But but Rich, seriously, I'd
love for you to say that to have that >> which is fair.
You just like
that's what I say. >> We're back. >> Anyway, back
to these bozos. Which is fair. You just like this movie. >> Yeah,
I'm an angry. >> Oh, no. I I also kind of Should we grab
>> Yeah, why not? >> It' be good to have
you know before rainy day. >> You never know. I got >> Why
am I so handsome right now? >> Oh my god, Dave. >> What
the hell? >> What the heck? >> Does anyone else Did
anyone else notice? Hey, I was going to say something, but I
didn't want to put you on the spot. >> I didn't want to
be weird. >> No, it's okay. You can put me on the >> Why
are your shoulders so goddamn wide? >> Why is your so chisel?
>> Cuz I'm a I don't know.